if you're graduating right now or you've
just graduated I would make a very
simple observation because I think
you're very lucky to be graduating now
because 25 years ago when people
graduated and went and let's say had a
job in Investment Banking and very
successful careers and let's say today
their and their middle to late 50s and
they've just retired and you meet them
at a cocktail party what do they tell
you about CEO of an investment bank they
tell you about the Peace Corps years and
what they did in the Peace Corps I'm
saying wait a minute you just had this
amazing life and you're talking about
the Peace Corps and then they say yeah
and now I'm gonna use the rest of my
life to do something meaningful made a
lot of money my kids are graduated
empty-nest and I know I'm gonna do
something meaningful and I say to myself
wow here's somebody who graduated and
basically did something meaningless for
a period of time and then decided to do
something meaningful and the reason I'm
so enthusiastic by people who graduate
today is that we're starting to
understand that it's possible to have
meaningful lives all the way along and
to be a social entrepreneur if you want
to put your entrepreneurial energy in
that way to do things that in fact do
mix market with mission it's in fact a
period today where you can take an
avocation and turn it into something
that's very intimately connected with
what you do and if you are you know
toying with taking a job because it pays
well but you hate it don't do that don't
ever do that because it is be the
saddest peer you're gonna wake up every
morning unless you really wake up and
not only smile about it but you tell
your spouse or your family what happened
and how excited you are that's the life
you want to live in more than ever
before
lots and lots
so people can do that and so that's why
I think graduating today would be really
interesting thirty years ago we were a
bit more in lockstep obedience and you
did things because you were supposed to
an opportunity didn't include making the
world better place